personal statement is something that
really concerns a lot of students in
their applications to the University and
it's really important to remember that
the personal statement forms one part of
much bigger process we're taking a lot
of information we're looking at
candidates and the personal statement is
false one aspect of it so before you
send anything in at all or even within
your you test form what we'll get is
your GCSE results your predicted a-level
results if you still have a s is your a
s results you've included them we'll get
a teacher's reference any admissions
tests information that you've sent
through any written work and also the
interview itself so the huge amount of
dates that we take in so in that sense
the personal statement you might think
is not hugely important now different
departments lose them in different ways
no sense them to worry about the key
thing is that you need to sell yourself
as well as possible and not worry too
much about how different departments or
indeed different universities are going
to use them because we also have to
remember it's can be sent to at least
five or four or five institutions and if
you do include in your personal
statement might be used as part of the
interview process itself so you're
effectively given license to a tutor to
bring something after you've written it
in but again that's nothing to worry
about just make sure that things that
you do put in your personal statement
reflect things that you're interested in
and reflect things that you are going to
feel confident about speaking under
pressure so preparation is also gonna be
the key at the second part and after
you've got through sending off your
personal statement it's also really
important to remember the personal
statement offers an opportunity for you
to include any extenuating circumstances
so if something's gone wrong any part of
your your current experience your what
Evers happen in your background that the
time to include it or mention it briefly
is in the personal statement it's really
important really really important that
your teachers get to see your personal
statement before because they're also
able to include any bits of information
that you're not able to to fit into your
own part of the personal statement at
Oxford they've printed off and often and
they come out on a sheet side-to-side
with the teachers reference
so these two things should come from
each other so it's really important your
schools involved in that process
two-thirds to 80% of your personal
statement should really focus on the
academic side so related for the course
of Occident you want to apply for leave
20% to apply and include information
about the person that makes you things
that excite you outside your academic
interest because we recognize you've got
to apply to for the universities using
this personal statement and they're
going to use that information in
different ways the key thing is keep it
personal keep it about you thank you so
much to Dan for agreeing to be
interviewed if you'd like to check out
more videos about Oxford and Cambridge
admissions then check out the playlist
that's on the screen now and linked in
the description below also take a look
at the social media links in the
description for Sint Peter's College
which is my old college there are links
to Facebook Twitter snapchat and
Instagram where you can see a snapshot
of student life at an Oxford College